welcome back to Washington journal for
about the next 40 minutes we're joined
by Linda leer who is good morning thank
you very much for coming in she's the
biographer among other things the
biographer of Rachel Carson and if you
were to describe Rachel Carson to
somebody who might never have heard of
her at all or who might know vaguely who
she is how would you describe Rachel
Carson Carson was a scientist and an
environmentalist who loved nature and
wanted to share that love with the
public by writing about it but also
became alarmed that we had overstepped
our bounds as human beings and were
harming ourselves and the environment
irrevocably and wanted to warn us about
that and I know that you think her if
she's obviously the author of four books
and and it's the view of many including
yourself I think that that some of the
early books are quite good as well and
maybe even better but the one that she's
best known for and I know we're gonna
try to put this under the robocam here
and show you that show our audience the
Silent Spring which is the book that
probably made her her reputation for the
ages it did and can you explain first of
all what led up to the writing of this
book and and what the what the impact of
the book was well the the agricultural
chemical companies were were big
business after World War two and and DDT
had been invented and created and used
widely during the war very successfully
against insect pests but after the war
it became commonly used in agriculture
to to kill manner of pests sprayed by
airplane without anybody's permission
over vast areas of America and Carson
became concerned that evidence was
showing her that wildlife was dying the
Patuxent refuge which is right up the
road in Largo Maryland Laurel Maryland
had done a lot of work on DDT and it
showed absolutely conclusively that it
was very harmful to fish and other
wildlife and they were dying by over
overuse what Carson called misuse she
wasn't against pesticides she was
against their misuse and their overuse
and they're ineffective use and so she
set out to to bring this kind
science to the public to make it
understandable and the book was
published in 1962 and caused an
incredible ruckus because he was a woman
without very many credentials in the way
the world worked telling us that the
government was lying that science was
wrong and that we should take another
look at what we were doing I want to
invite our callers our listeners our
viewers to call in remind you we have
three lines Republicans 202 seven three
seven zero zero zero two Democrats two O
two seven three seven zero zero zero one
independents and all others two oh two
six two eight zero two zero five I've
said that Linda Lear is the biographer
of Rachel Carson here is that biography
Rachel Carson a witness for nature why
this picture on the cover well two
reasons one because Carson was a very
romantic almost mystical person in her
spiritual relationship with nature she
was first of all a nature writer and a
brilliant writer or otherwise she
couldn't have made such a boring and
deadly subject such as DDT palatable to
the public as a bestseller and I chose
the picture because it's also by one of
her best friends and colleagues here in
town shirley briggs and it sort of
typifies the mystical sense of Carson's
spirituality let's take a look at that
when you open the book you talk about
her and I just want to read the first
paragraph for our listeners here most of
all it was her determination that set
her apart as a child rachel louise
carson decided that she would be a
writer a literary talent perhaps genius
and a hard-driving intelligence brought
her that but at the base of it there was
a ferocious will this was a woman who
had a sense very early on in her life
that she was meant to do something
important it's rather unusual for us to
meet these kinds of people she was very
single-minded very determined that she
wasn't sure exactly what her talent was
going to lead her to but she was
confident that she had it and confident
that somehow she'd find out what she was
to do with it and that something that to
do with it was science well originally
she thought she would simply be a writer
right and she published her first short
story depending on where I read two
different ages one
was age 10 was age 11 either one is
pretty extraordinary but there was a
wonderful magazine back then that
children wrote in the thing with this
magazine and they had contests and
children could write in it
Carson wrote early stories and they won
badges and were actually paid if they
won so many badges and reached a certain
level so she published stories mainly
these were stories about her hometown in
spring
Springdale Pennsylvania and what she was
doing out in nature with her mother who
was her constant companion and her
teacher and later on then she wrote of
course about nature itself and she was
really an acclaimed nature writer and at
some point I guess it was in college she
something shifted right in college she
she found that she was not exactly
terribly imaginative or at least she
thought she wasn't and so that she was
better suited she finally learned to
write about what was that the other end
of her microscope in a biology class her
mind was expanded and she was turned on
and and she decided that here was
something to write about and did she go
on and I guess that did become she got
degrees in science she got a master's
degree in science from Johns Hopkins and
then went to work and then went to Woods
Hole where she first saw the sea for the
first time and then finally got a job
this was during the Depression she
wanted to go on for a doctorate and
couldn't financially got a job with the
Fish and Wildlife Service or what was
then the biological survey and got they
got a job with the Interior Department
and Fish and Wildlife this is somebody
lived inland all her life in western
Pennsylvania got Springdale is near
Pittsburgh the river got to the got to
the ocean at age 20 something I saw it
and that was became the huge well she
had always had this passion for the sea
and she lived on the Allegheny River at
a particularly wide part of the river so
that I have a feeling that water was in
her blood from from way off and that she
loved literature about the sea and was
very knowledgeable so when she saw it it
was just a kind of match okay now there
are exhibits and things people can go to
see that's right about her and I think
we have some actually we have some
footage of one but why don't you talk a
little bit about what where people can
go and well there's a new exhibit in at
the Department of Interior Museum
main interior on Carson it's a small
exhibit but it's very very powerful
exhibit I think that explains her life
and her work and and particularly her
some 15 years at the Department of
Interior where she was ended up as
editor in chief of all fish and wildlife
publications now if somebody wants an
entry point of course your biography is
is the definitive biography I give you
another plug here at the Rachel Carson
witness for nature and say it's a big
book but also she has written several
books yeah Carson wrote four books
that's right and and the the most
important of her early nature books was
a book called the the sea around us
which became an enormous bestseller and
really put her name in the world on the
world map it was an attempt to inform
the public about all the the science of
Oceanography that had to come out during
World War two and to tell them about
what was really under the sea now this
is sold 200,000 copies this is
extraordinary it's a book about the the
sea what can you pinpoint one thing that
made it fascinating to people well I
think anybody who goes to the beach is
fascinated by the sea and when they pick
up a show you know what what kind of
creature lived there under those waves
you know where did they come from and
where do they go and that's what she
explained and very very common but
almost poetic terms let's let our
callers into this conversation for our
first call from Jacksonville Florida
good morning yes
I've got a question about Carson I think
her her book about Silent Spring clearly
has a great deal of merit but I think
we're at sort of disappointing that you
would include a preface by a buffoon
like Al Gore who would write what was
his book earth Arsena balanced earth and
balance were it clearly depends our
entire economy and everything we've got
in this country is dependent on
essentially redistribution or pet cash
payments to the developing world in
masked in environmental protection which
is based on really bad science or
perhaps not even bad science but
questionable science
- whether greenhouse gases are actually
causing a ozone hole okay let's get a
response
Algrim well I had nothing to do with
that preface let's put it let's put that
out first the preface was it was
contracted by the publisher Mountain
Miss Lin who publishes Silent Spring and
it was the new addition to to Silent
Spring that they asked him to write the
preface so it was shall we say
politically timely this book sells
25,000 copies a year still book still
sells twenty first came out in 1962
25,000 copies a year there are a lot of
authors who would love to sell 25,000 at
all you betcha
oh that's that's pretty impressive
here's another book and I just want to
mention this before we go to the next
call Lost Woods the discovered writing
of Rachel Carson which you edited and
wrote an introduction for this is by
beacon press published by beacon press
and Boston I believe right what's this
book about this is an attempt to bring
some of Carson's unpublished writing to
the to the attention of the public the
the four books that she wrote the under
the sea wind the edge of the sea the sea
around us and and a posthumously
published the sense of wonder available
but a lot of Carson's other writing is
just as good and so I tried to compile
some letters some early childhood
writing some speeches some papers that
she had written that would never see the
light of day yeah because they weren't
book-length
into an edition that gave people a sense
of Carson if there's a favorite passage
you have in there you know I want to
take another call clear but if there's
something you want to read to us and
also why don't we get some of the photos
and then we can show those as we're
taking another call if you want to just
if you can them to me I'll put them
under here we got photos of Rachel
Carson at various times in her life how
old was she in this picture of Carson at
the heyday of her time in the 40s at the
Fish and Wildlife Service it's one of
the rare pictures that you see of Carson
healthy and smiling she died in nineteen
she died in 1964 only 18 months after
Silent Spring was published of
misdiagnosed breast cancer and she was
56 years old let's go ahead and romiska
and not getting some more of our callers
in they're all waiting Atlanta Georgia
Republican line
good morning good morning curious
missileer could comment whether Rachel
Carson felt would feel that the
trade-off of banning chemicals like DDT
and other pesticides that control
insects
if the trade-off of millions of people
worldwide who die yearly due to things
like malaria and things like that if
that is a Rachel Carson would consider
that a good trade-off it's a very good
question and and it's it's it's complex
indeed
Carson was not against against as I say
it was not against pesticides and and
certainly in the third world and when
places where malaria is back with a
vengeance it's it's a chemical that
needs to be considered to be used as do
others I think there is a trade-off
Carson was not an ideologue she was not
someone who would say we must never do
this she was trying to tell us that as
human beings we were out of control in
our use of technology to to kill things
that may not be really pests but just
inconveniences and in our lives and that
we ought to just think about what we
were doing long term there were some
incidents that really led to this inside
is referred in my reading there was
something that happen in Duxbury
Massachusetts right well there was I
think I think the birds the bird issue
gets a lot of people and back in the 40s
and 50s birds bird-watching was a was a
was maybe more important than it is now
I'm not sure but the mosquitoes were
suppose the planes sprayed for
mosquitoes in Duxbury Massachusetts and
one of Carson's literary friends had a
sanctuary there and her birds were just
died horrible deaths and she wrote
Carson and said can't you find someone
in Congress to do something about this
situation then there was a big fire ant
plague where the Department of
Agriculture was was covering the south
with with hundreds and hundreds of
pounds of dieldrin and other very
powerful chemicals to kill the fire ant
the a that was out of control to
wildlife were dying and then the
Department of Agriculture started
covering up the fact that all this
wildlife was actually dying from their
overuse of of a very dangerous chemical
our next call
Providence New Jersey Democratic line
good morning violence are you there yes
we have a we have a Silent Spring here
and at one time we had wild honeybees
that as soon as the first crocus was
blooming there they be where they came
from and where they stayed it was hard
to tell but now they are not there we
have a small orchard and up 30 years ago
when it would be in bloom well it would
be buzzing with activities of all types
of bees and now it's silent well that's
absolutely correct and and bees are one
of the the lightning rods if you will of
our pesticide use
so our frogs and amphibians and there
are places that people write to me about
the fact that there are no more croaking
frogs and their ponds and where did they
go we have certainly done damage to the
to the universe and to the earth and
we're reaping the repercussions and the
change in diversity the change of
species the alteration of species no
question about it you know there was
something that's interesting she's one
of the 100 notable Americans in Time
magazine and Time magazine have Peter
Matheson the author wrote an
appreciation of her for the magazine
talking about when Silent Spring was
published in 1962 and what the reaction
was she was derided by the chemical
industry as an hysterical woman but even
more interesting is that peter matheson
writes here the time zone reviewer
deplored Carson's quote
oversimplifications and downright errors
many of the scary generalizations and
there are lots of them are patently
unsound it was a very in some quarters a
very hostile reaction to this very
hostile it's interesting to note that on
her death in 1964 Time magazine wrote a
wonderful
laudatory review of course and
completely changed their opinion of
the efficacy of Carson's science so they
did a real double take about face but
the the chemical industry was scared to
death because they were certain and they
were right that the housewives of the
world we're gonna stop buying bug bombs
and sprays and their their revenues were
gonna go down and people were gonna
start reading labels and questioning
what they were doing and with chemicals
and maybe even government regulation
would get worse so they put up a
tremendous campaign of a quarter of a
million dollars which in 1962 was an
outrageous amount of money to try a
silence and discredit Carson of course
they went after her as a as a woman on
gendered terms and tried to make her out
as a hysteric alarmist but I gather
that's sort of backed by backfired it
did backfire one of the reasons it
backfired was because President Kennedy
took it quite seriously it took the book
seriously it was first published in
pre-publication formed by the New Yorker
in three serials and that in that made
the intelligentsia aware of this book
kennedy read it in The New Yorker and
started some committee investigation
about the use of chemicals and in a
press conference even mentioned it so
that gave her a quite a legitimate boost
up and all during the time in which this
chemical discredit bation campaign was
going on the government was working to
hold hearings and in 1963 they did okay
our next call from Madison Wisconsin
Democratic line good morning good
morning I'm very pleased that you've
written this book and I want to thank
you for the work you've done that's an
enormous amount of work I'm sure thank
you I am called to comment that I think
it's important we celebrate the lives of
these people who stand up to the powers
that want to silence voices that are
looking intelligently at the issues we
confront and certainly we've had this in
the past of people like Alva Leopold who
lived in Madison when he was working in
the city he was hung in effigy further
parts of the state were attempts to
bring people to awareness about the
biological impacts
large deer herds for instance I think um
I wanted to share with you that a few
weeks ago we started a series of Earth
Day Commission's and we set the words to
music of John Muir Aldo Leopold and
Gaylord Nelson and mr. Nelson sent a
foreword and I think very highly Rachel
Carson Carson and she's on the short
lists of authors whose words we intend
to have set in some way 400 they
commissioned in the coming two or three
years
well good just don't make her an icon
because she was a real live person who
cared deeply about the earth here's a
cartoon from The New Yorker I think not
Saturday Review this shows how much
she'd sort of penetrated the culture
there's a man at a bar complaining to
the bartender and I don't know if we can
even read it here but it's at the here
here is the caption I had just come to
terms with fallout and along comes
Rachel Carson think that's a very
interesting cartoon because the
background to the whole DDT controversy
was radioactive fallout and the public
during the 40s and 50s course was very
familiar with the with--we fallout work
the silence of it the fact that the
penetrated bodies that have got into
your bones that you didn't have to
swallow it
eat it or do anything else that it was
there and Carson used that knowledge
very directly in Silent Spring the first
chemical that she mentions in the book
is not DDT but it's a radioactive
element strontium 90 and she throughout
the book talks about the silent killer
and the fact that the there is silence
in the spring here's a another cartoon
here that's a praying mantis praying and
it says god bless mama and papa and
Rachel Carson where did that run
somewhere in a magazine yeah it was I
think that was also in the Saturday
Review I'm not really sure we couldn't
find a source but the insects of the
world had a right to be grateful to
Carson in the sense that she cared about
all of life and she was trying to tell
us that we are interconnected so what
we're doing to the natural world were
also doing to ourselves Jackson
Mississippi Republican line good morning
yes I was in
Italy during the Second World War when
DDT was used to wipe out a typhus
epidemic a lot of soldiers were killed
during the First World War
because a typist I have one question
there's this white Caucasian American
believe that seeing the bald eagle is
better than the million lives at a loss
to malaria in non-white third-world
countries thanks I don't think so I
don't think that's the the the
opposition or what she was trying to
talk about these are their ways to
control mosquito populations now that
that are as effective as DDT there are
well I'm not I'm not the scientist so I
can't speak to exactly what chemicals
are out there now but in in third-world
populations the cheapest chemical is
still DDT there's no question about it
okay yeah and it's still widely used
it's still widely used i I think we
should point out that though DDT was
banned for production in the United
States in the early 70s it has been
exported around the world by the United
States ever since it was only banned for
domestic production and use but but it's
widely used it is still manufactured in
the United States there's got to be
exported exported right okay Elton Elton
Maryland calling on the independent line
good morning it's hi one of the things
that I've noticed is there are there in
this area there's a complete lack of
wild honeybees I think that I read 90%
of the population of the wild honeybees
have disappeared and I'm a gardener and
I'm noticing that there simply are no
wild honeybees also one of the things
that we're seeing is a complete
disappearance of amphibians worldwide
and I'm very alarmed because I see these
as being the canary in the coalmine
type of signs and also around the world
we're seeing a very high cancer rate and
this is something that you know Rachel
Carson tried to address in her book and
I would just like to hear your comment
on that thank you thank you yes another
caller mentioned the honeybee and and
there are certainly Canaries warning
signals here but I think that it it's
wider than the amphibians or the
Canaries it's a change in in what
wildlife is is is be able to survive not
only because of chemicals but because of
invasions to their habitats and so forth
so the earth is changing the climate is
changing the earth is changing and what
we've done to it is clearly to make the
mix of chemicals that we've put in the
air in the water and on the land quite a
melange of chemical soup and no one is
really sure exactly what that means long
term Staten Island New York Democratic
line good morning good morning let me
just turn down the sound sure just want
to remind everybody when you get ready
to go on the air and of course I'm going
to surprise you when that happens but
just have your mute button ready my
question is - I have - I have a question
and a comment the question is where or
how did Rachel Carson research the
information about the chemicals and the
chemical companies that went into Silent
Spring that's my question and my comment
is I now have a silent backyard in the
middle of Staten Island New York City
since they've been spraying for the West
Nile virus here my carpenter bees whom I
really don't like I finally got rid of
them with the spraying for the West Nile
virus but I enjoyed seeing them and they
were there for 20 years until where
summer interesting I can't hang up
anyways okay the Carson was not a field
researcher either for the sea around us
or for any of her books she was her
great talent was as a synthesizer and
what she did of course was to ferret out
information about that the that the
chemical companies the wildlife science
cancer science that had for some time
and put it together in Silent Spring and
her bibliography is quite rich in that
book she gives a long long bibliography
of what she's used she followed a
certain line of it
independent inquiry and in in Silent
Spring that linked cancer certain kinds
of cancers to pesticides and the use of
pesticides that's certainly been borne
out but she didn't one wasn't able to
investigate all the lines that now are
open and people such as Theo Coburn have
been able to research recently I want to
point out that the new york university
department of journalism picked the top
100 works of journalism in the United
States in the 20th century and Silent
Spring his number two behind only
Hiroshima John Hersey's book that was
actually first printed again just like
Silent Spring in The New Yorker hard
there's no question that Carson changed
the way she's a revolutionary because
she changed the way we look at the earth
and have a relationship with the world
before Rachel Carson we were content to
think that human beings were really in
control
Luther Montana Republican line good
morning good morning good show first
time got on my heart's in my throat
welcome welcome since Rachel Carson's
book did a good thing I'm sure for our
environment about a lot of people to
life however I live in the West since my
military days and and before and I see
all kinds of things that are restricting
life in the West the Eastern
establishment dictates our tree cutting
the Forest Service people can't even put
in a bid for some tree cutting which
might help allay some of the fires that
we have every season and that we're
getting prepared for now it's not worth
the money that the lawsuits that the
tree huggers put forth they don't do it
anymore I don't know what's gonna happen
but I live right near the forest so I'm
an environmentalist once I've got my
house in the forest the developers are
the bad guys okay call it Thanks why
don't we go to Madison Connecticut
independent line good morning
all right go right ahead caller I was
wondering I have to be a devotee of
conservationism and I wondered whether
anybody had heard the program the other
night with mr. Moyers on where he had a
doctor that had done tests I believe on
mr. Moyers blood in the woods he found
83 different kind of chemicals in the
blood that are from pesticides all the
different things that we use in the
environment and mr. Moyers asked whether
that would have been in his blood 60
years ago would it would it have been in
people's blood 60 years ago and the
doctor said no so that we very
definitely are you know getting to the
point where we're making ourselves sick
that's right and then that was Carson's
point that we we don't know the
long-term outcome of what we're doing to
the earth and what we're doing to
ourselves is the same thing that we're
doing to the earth well I remind viewers
listeners tomorrow c-span Washington
Journal and Sunday Gary Bauer former
Republican presidential candidate now
with campaign for working families Laura
March with the American Civil Liberties
Union and Jeffrey Bell a Republican
political consultant and I'd also like
to read to something here this is some
of some of Rachel Carson's own writing
this is again in this appreciation in
time which I went and found on their
website which is which is pretty good
the beauty of the living world I was
trying to save she wrote in a letter to
a friend in 1962 has always been
uppermost in my mind that and anger at
the senseless brutish things that were
being done I have felt bound by a solemn
obligation to do what I could if I
didn't at least try I could never be
happy again in nature but now I can
believe that I have at least helped a
little it would be unrealistic to
believe one book could bring a complete
change that that's a wonderful quote and
if the end comes at the end of Silent
Spring where she also talks about what's
what she was trying to do with her her
work at her life and this particular
letter to her friend was to suggest that
while Carson knew she was dying by this
time she certainly didn't think one book
would make a difference but in fact one
book did make a difference and the
hearings that she testified at made a
difference and began our
our current concern with clean water and
clean air and it took a long time but we
finally got to where we we can't say
that we don't know what we're doing
that's the big change whatever it is
that we're doing we also know that we
are spraying our Lauren our lawns we are
pouring fuel oil down our sewers we are
doing something and we know we're doing
it what was the most concrete way in
which this made a difference right after
the book was that the hearings happen
but we're laws passed as a result in
well the clean water and the Clean Air
Act came fairly fairly on the heels we
especially the Clean Water Act I think
that was the first big legislation to
feel the effect of Carsen but it took
ten years with the maybe the bigger
thing was that the wildlife system began
to really take off and people began to
understand that we needed to save places
there was another of Carson's Crusades
of course was to save not only the
seashore the ocean areas but to save
wildlife refuges and to allow people to
go out and see nature and therefore to
love it and her her basic credo was that
you can't destroy something that you
love but first you have to learn to love
it and this is the message and the sense
of wonder and you can see from this map
there's a there is a Rachel Carson
refuge up in Maine and Wells Maine this
is a map of the refuge system of the
United States which you can see there
lots and lots of wonderful places that
are trying to preserve species that are
trying to to keep give people a chance
to see what real nature is all about
Akron Ohio Democratic line good morning
hi I was just wondering so she mentioned
about she wasn't an Ida log miss Carson
right the question I had is what do you
think of the Earth Day environmental
wackos that use a lot of this junk
science to scare people I mean 20 years
ago they said we were going to have an
ice age now we have global warming etc
etc and you know they kind of really
take true environmentalist
off the you know the the face of the
screen here and and make them look kind
of silly rather than the people who are
seriously concerned about the
environment okay well I guess I have to
say that I think some sometimes the
extreme points of view when they're
expressed at least serve the purpose of
getting our attention certainly over the
long haul you're right however that we
need to to be moderate in in in our
thinking about what's really going on
moderate in the sense that you don't
jump to one conclusion or another
ideologically the Carson certainly was
adamant that that we needed to know what
we were doing a long time out that we
acted too fast that we were we were a
country in a society that what would go
for the quick fix that was something
that she thought was wrong and it would
fundamentally do us in Powell Wyoming
calling on the Republican line good
morning good morning
go right ahead caller you're on the air
hello hi you're up but you got to mute
your TV yes oh just a moment right
hitting the wrong button okay all right
my concern is I heard the program on
your companion network the other night
about the biggest thing as far as
immigration is concerned is
overpopulation and I wondered if the
author of this book addressed that in a
way that's a that's a good question - I
I don't know that I was writing a book
about Rachel Carson in her life as a
biographer Carson didn't often address
population but I know from my own
research that she was very concerned as
as almost any biologists and scientists
would be couldn't help it be with the
problems of overpopulation then while
she didn't directly comment on that in
her her writings she was concerned about
it anybody who's the main we've got this
I think on that on the camera here you
can see the Rachel Carson Wildlife
Refuge is down in the southeastern
corner remain right along the seashore
here having a well must have been there
yes I certainly have and
didn't she have a home she had a home in
Boothbay off the coast of Boothbay
Harbor which is farther north she never
lived around wells which is where the
refuge is but this was the refuge that
was already in the system that was named
after her in the 70s but she lived up in
Maine during the summers and it was
Maine that was really dear to her heart
and she would work in the tide pools I
think we showed a picture of Carson
looking at the tide pools earlier and it
was Maine that won her heart and where
she went for refuge and this by the way
I see Kennebunkport the home of the
family summers right there and is right
right there our next call Toledo Ohio
Democratic line good morning oh you
aren't I'm here on you're on as you okay
thank you yeah I was just wondering what
the lady thinks about these people
fertilizing their lawns all the time
because a lot of times I go out I got
people around me that fertilizer you
can't even go out and breathe the air
and and I say in the last maybe five six
years I've yet to see a butterfly in my
neighborhood Wow well I personally think
that we need to be more responsible
about what we're doing to our to our
lawns and our inevitably our groundwater
which is what what's being poisoned and
the the rivers of our nation are
reflective of the runoff problems that
we're having and and certainly that
comes from from misuse and overuse of
chemicals Stillwater Oklahoma Republican
line good morning good morning I was
having as much fun listening to the
other colors as I was listening to your
conversations I would be interested in
your opinion on the overall picture that
people place Rachel Carson and and that
type of environmental awareness in that
the feedback you have gotten in general
as you're working on this book
I've had wonderful letters and a
wonderful reaction to bringing Carson
back to to our attention she she really
is a name that's evoked at every Earth
Day celebration but people knew very
little about her struggle in her life
and and just how dedicated she was to
keeping our planet and our human lives
healthy and wholesome and so I've had
I've had wonderful response to to the
book and to the biography and to talking
about Carson and I do we do have a
website about Carson WWV Rachel Carson
org we try to put up information not
only about her but about links to topics
that she considered important and here
it is and here's a quote another quote
in Rachel Carson's own words quote the
more clearly we can focus our attention
on the wonders and realities of the
universe about us the less taste we
shall have for destruction our last call
for Linda Lear biographer Rachel Carson
comes from Monroe Michigan calling on
the democratic line good morning caller
are you there I am here yes I was
calling about in question of different
NGOs and non-governmental organizations
for instance the Sierra Club and
National Audubon Society they've stated
that that overpopulation is such a
problem and that they're they're
interested in eliminating or not
necessarily limiting but through long
term plans definitely decreasing the
population on the US or the world it
seems that you can actually fit and
different scientists have said this so
you could actually fit everyone in the
u.s. within the city limits of
Tallahassee Florida okay well I again I
I think this is a problem a worldwide
problem and that it's probably a proper
for the
NGOs that are concerned about our planet